[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und guten
Abend Champions League um mehr gibt's
von Sven Voss und auch von mir einen
schönen guten Abend und wir beginnen die
Sendung mit einer Entlassung
[Musik]
es ist der eine Fehler zu viel
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck und lässt
seinen Staatssekretär reichen nach neuen
belastenden Erkenntnissen
Kampfjets für die Ukraine einige
europäische Länder sind für die
Lieferung von F16 und wollen Piloten
ausbilden Deutschland hält sich zurück
schwere Unwetter Norditalien durch
Überschwemmungen und Erdrutsche sterben
mindestens acht Menschen
über Wochen hat
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck an
seinem Staatssekretär festgehalten jetzt
muss Patrick reichen doch sein Hut
nehmen der Druck auf Habeck wurde immer
größer und es sind neue Informationen
aufgetaucht wonach der Staatssekretär
gegen interne Regeln des Ministeriums
verstoßen haben soll worum es bei den
Vorwürfen genau geht zeigt Ihnen
im Zentrum der Affäre Patrick reichen
Staatssekretär im Wirtschaftsministerium
einer der Architekten der Energiewende
zuerst geriet er in die Kritik wegen der
Besetzung eines spitzenpostens kreischen
war an der Auswahl eines neuen
Geschäftsführers bei der bundeseigenen
Energieagentur Dehner beteiligt der
posten sollte an Michael Schäfer gehen
dass dieser graichens Trauzeuge war
teilte reichen nicht sofort mit es wurde
erst später bekannt und nun kommt noch
mehr belastendes hinzu es hat damit zu
tun dass gleich ins Schwester Verena
reichen im Vorstand des Landesverbands
Berlin des Bundes für Umwelt und
Naturschutz Bund ist ein Projekt des
BUND sollte finanziell vom
Wirtschaftsministerium gefördert werden
Patrick reichen hatte das per
Unterschrift gebilligt das ist ein
Verstoß gegen die internen Ethik-Regeln
der Opposition reicht die Entlassung von
gleichen nicht für
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck war der
Staatssekretär einer der wichtigsten
Mitarbeiter am morgentraut habe ich für
die Presse mehr dazu von Winnie hescher
es sind ziemlich viele Zettel die Robert
Habeck mit zur Pressekonferenz gebracht
hat meistens redet er frei heute liest
der Wort für Wort von seinem Manuskript
ab die Angelegenheit ist juristisch wie
politisch verzwickt öffentliche
Kündigung seine Staatssekretärs Patrick
reichen
es ist der eine Fehler zu viel
deshalb habe ich heute diese
Entscheidung getroffen es ist eine
weitreichende
schwere Entscheidung weitreichend für
mein Haus schwer für mich und sehr hart
für Patrick reichen reichen war einer
von harbex wichtigsten Mitarbeitern
grüner Umbau der Wirtschaft Einhaltung
der Klimaziele Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien dafür war reichen zuständig und
es war seine Idee ab nächstem Jahr keine
Öl und Gasheizung mehr einzubauen das
erklärt auch die Reaktion der FDP ihr
geht es schon nicht mehr um reichen
sondern um sein Gesetz und uns als
Parlament fehlt jetzt einen
Ansprechpartner für dieses
heizungsgesetz und deswegen meine ich
Herr harberg wäre gut darin beraten
jetzt einen neuen Zeitplan für dieses
heizungsgesetz vorzulegen und damit auch
deutlich zu machen dass er ein
heizungsgesetz möchte das oft auf der
Basis des Koalitionsvertrags steht
dagegen klingt die Kritik an habe und
reichen von der CDU sachlich zahm das
was ist
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium kraftvoll
postuliert Transparenz Brandmauern das
muss tatsächlich eingehalten werden und
deshalb können wir jetzt nicht einfach
zur Tagesordnung übergehen der
Bundeskanzler beläst die Angelegenheit
ganz bei Harbeck
mit einem gleichen selbst habe ich gut
zusammengearbeitet und ich gehe davon
aus dass der Wirtschaftsminister jetzt
seine Arbeit mit voller Kraft fortsetzt
der wird am Ende der Pressekonferenz
noch gefragt wie ergreifens Nachfolger
aussuchen werde also ich würde nicht
mehr ein Trauzeugen jetzt als
Staatssekretär berufen
das nennt man wohl Galgen Humor Patrick
reichen ist weg Robert Habeck aber weiß
dass auch er den Schaden hat
Staatssekretär reichen muss jetzt also
sein Posten räumenergie warum kommt
dieser Schritt jetzt
weil Patrick reichen nicht mehr zu
halten gewesen ist kritiker hatten das
schon letzte Woche so gesehen da hat
Robert Habeck noch dagegen gehalten aber
jetzt nachdem nach hausinternen
Ermittlungen eben weitere Vorwürfe und
Verstöße bekannt geworden sind gegen die
Verhaltensregeln die extra eingeführt
worden sind um Filz zu vermeiden musste
er handeln sonst wäre die ganze Sache
und der Vorwurf der fährt dann
Wirtschaft am Ende dann auch an ihm
selbst an Robert Habeck hängen geblieben
und wie beschädigt ist Minister Habeck
trotzdem nicht diese ganze Affäre er hat
jetzt aktuell zwei Probleme zum einen
muss er den Vorwurf wieder abschütteln
dass er bei grünen Netzwerken bereit ist
ein Auge zuzudrücken und da wird man ihn
sehr genau beobachten und zum anderen
muss er dringend die Lücke füllen die da
weggegangen von Patrick reichen reiste
denn reichen war der wichtigste Mann in
der Energie und wärmewende und da geht
es jetzt ja gerade aktuell um das
Gebäude Energie gesetzt jeden Tag ohne
eine Nachbesetzung wird die
Verhandlungen über dieses Gesetz
erschweren und die Grünen haben sich
fest vorgenommen das Gesetz bis zur
Sommerpause durch den Bundestag zu
bringen da drängt die Zeit also jetzt
sehr danke schön in Berlin
die Ukraine kann in ihrem Abwehrkampf
gegen Russland auf westliche Kampfjets
hoffen mehrere europäische Staaten
wollen dafür die Weichen stellen
konkret geht es um F16 Kampfflugzeuge
der Vorteil dieser Flugzeugtyp ist in
der NATO in großer Stückzahl vorhanden
und relativ leicht zu bedienen bereits
im April hatten Polen und die Slowakei
Kampfjets geliefert allerdings noch vom
sowjetischen Typ mit 29 Florian neuhahn
weiß mehr
treffen sich gestern Abend zwei
Regierungschefs der eine aus den
Niederlanden hat F16 Kampfjets der
andere aus Großbritannien könnte Piloten
daran ausbilden lassen im Anschluss
erklärt ein Sprecher des Briten beide
hätten vereinbart eine internationale
Koalition aufzubauen um die Ukraine mit
Kampfflugzeug Kapazitäten auszustatten
von der Ausbildung bis zur Beschaffung
von F16 Jets westliche F16 Kampfjets es
wäre die nächste Stufe der militärischen
Unterstützung der Ukraine das was die
seit Monaten fördert diverse
NATO-Staaten haben diese Jets im Bestand
nicht aber Deutschland also liefert man
auch keine Kampfjets sagt der Kanzler
heute
in Hinblick auf uns sind keine
Anforderungen da wir haben uns darauf
konzentriert und konzentrieren uns auf
das was wir tun sprich Panzer und
Luftabwehr um Kampfjets kümmern sich
andere der niederländische premiermark
rütte zurückhaltend positiv
wir können erst dann etwas ankündigen
wenn es auch fertig ist aber wir bauen
an einer Koalition mit Ländern die mit
uns darüber nachdenken wie das möglich
wäre
jetzt also auch westliche Kampfjets je
länger Russland an dem Krieg führt desto
mehr rote Linien des Westens fallen
offenbar noch aber steht diese Kampf
steht Koalition nicht noch fehlt vor
allem die Zusage des wichtigsten
naturlandes die Zusage aus den USA auch
dort wird jetzt intensiv abgewogen wie
groß wäre der militärische nutzen und
wie groß das Risiko einer Eskalation
wer genau unterstützt die Lieferung und
wie groß ist die Gefahr einer Eskalation
wenn Sie das nachlesen möchten dann
schauen Sie einfach in der ZDF heute App
das für viele Länder so wichtige
getreideabkommen zwischen der Ukraine
und Russland ist ein weiteres Mal
verlängert worden wieder um zwei Monate
das gab der türkische Präsident Erdogan
als Vermittler zwischen beiden Ländern
bekannt
Moskau hatte nach dem Überfall auf die
Ukraine zunächst all ihre Häfen
blockieren lassen seit dem Abkommen im
Sommer letzten Jahres konnten rund 30
Millionen Tonnen Getreide exportiert
werden
Deutschland und das Emirat Kata wollen
trotz Differenzen ihre Zusammenarbeit
vertiefen einen entsprechender Erklärung
unterzeichneten Außenministerin berborg
und ihre Kollege alfani in Doha der
stellte Investitionen und mehr
Zusammenarbeit bei der
energiewendenaussicht warburg-
Sturz der Bundesregierung und die
Entführung von Bundesgesundheitsminister
Lauterbach geplant haben beim Waffenkauf
gerieten sie jedoch an ein verdeckten
Ermittler und so flog eine mutmaßliche
Terrorgruppe aus reichsbürgern auf fünf
Angeklagte müssen sich jetzt vor dem
Oberlandesgericht Koblenz verantworten
über die Prozessbeginn berichtet
sarattacke
eine pensionierte Lehrerin und Theologen
ein erfolgloser Comedian zwei
Ex-Soldaten und ein ex-bahn Mitarbeiter
fünf mutmaßliche Terroristen die sich
vereinte Patrioten nannten sitzen auf
der Anklagebank die Bundesanwaltschaft
wirft den Angeklagten vor eine
Vereinigung gegründet zu haben deren
Ziel darin bestand die bestehende
staatliche Ordnung der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland zu beseitigen und durch eine
eigene zu ersetzen seit vorbereitet es
kann jetzt jeden Tag losgehen nennt es
Marschbefehl wenn ihr wollt das System
muss weg das sollen sie sich über den
messenger-dienst telegram geschrieben
haben konkret sollen sie unter anderem
geplant haben den
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach zu entführen
hier geht es also um Kräfte die eine
also Absicht haben auch den Staat und
die Demokratie zu destabilisieren es ist
nicht das einzige Verfahren rund um
Reichsbürger mit dem sich die
Bundesanwaltschaft aktuell beschäftigt
nach Angaben des Verfassungsschutzes
sind der Szene der Reichsbürger und
Selbstverwalter deutschlandweit etwa
23.000 Personen zuzurechnen etwa 2100
davon gelten als gewaltorientiert heute
wurde hier am Oberlandesgericht in
Koblenz ein Schlaglicht auf ein
mutmaßliches Terrornetzwerk geworfen das
als solches auf den ersten Blick nicht
erkennbar ist die Angeklagten extrem
verschieden sie sollen aber im Ziel
geeint gewesen sein die Macht in
Deutschland zu übernehmen was so abstrus
klingt ist gleichzeitig brandgefährlich
denn sie sollen bereits im Besitz von
Waffen gewesen sein das mutmaßliche
Terrornetzwerk soll nun an mehr als 40
Verhandlungstagen ausgeleuchtet werden
eigentlich braucht Deutschland dringend
neuen Wohnraum doch es wird immer
weniger statt mehr gebaut im März
brachte die Zahl der Baugenehmigungen
weiter ein
29,6% weniger als im Vorjahresmonat
meldet das Statistische Bundesamt damit
geht es seit fast einem Jahr durchgängig
abwärtsgrund sind die hohen Baupreise
bei gleichzeitig stark gestiegenden
Kreditzinsen
die Entwicklung künstlicher Intelligenz
schreitet rasant voran und damit mehren
sich auch die Warnungen jetzt sprach
sich auch der Entwickler des
selbstlernenden textprogramms Chat GPT
Sam Oldman mos Senat für eine
Regulierung der Technik aus
staatliche Eingriffe sein entscheidend
um die Risiken immer leistungsfähigerer
ki-systeme zu mindern er schlug dafür
die Gründung einer US-amerikanischen
oder globalen Behörde vor
wer als Kind sexualisierte Gewalt
erlittenhart muss ein Leben lang kämpfen
um nicht daran zu zerbrechen so geht es
unzähligen opfernde der katholischen
Kirche 9 Betroffene aus dem Erzbistum
München und Freising gehen gerade mit
einem Befreiungsschlag an die
Öffentlichkeit mit Fahrrädern pilgerten
sie nach Rom und überreichten heute den
Papst einen Brief in dem steht was
sexualisierte Gewalt wirklich bedeutet
und wie dringend die Kirche etwas tun
muss Jutta sonnewald und Barbara
heiliger Vater wir sind von München
gekommen um Ihnen unser Herz zu bringen
ein Herz aus Gitterstäben fragil und
kantig dies das Geschenk der Missbrauchs
Betroffenen für Papst franziskus bei
ihrer Privataudienz auf dem Petersplatz
ein Symbol für ihr Leid und ihren
Schmerz mit dem sie noch heute kämpfen
ganz wesentlich war dass er auch eher
auf sein Herz gedeutet hat und
ich denke er hat doch schon was
verstanden und es lässt uns
zuversichtlich die Zukunft schauen
außerdem haben die Betroffenen den
Pontifex einen Brief übergeben mit der
Bitte er mir über alles tun um
Missbrauch zu verhindern in allen
Winkeln der Welt und das ist unsere
Botschaft alles beginnt vor elf Tagen in
München eine Gruppe macht sich auf eine
Reise die ist so noch nie gab Frauen und
Männer die als Kinder von Geistlichen
sexuell missbraucht wurden radeln von
München über die Alpen nach Rom es ist
eine Pilgerfahrt voller Begegnungen
Tränen Konfrontation und der Suche nach
Gemeinschaft und Gespräch mit Bürgern
Fahrern und Bischöfen
die Betroffenen wollen das Thema
Missbrauch endlich aus der tabu-zone
holen wir leben jetzt gerade dass sich
unglaublich viele Menschen mit uns
kommen aufzustehen zu sprechen sich zu
outen vielleicht auch an die
Öffentlichkeit zu gehen und dadurch
bitte passieren dass Kirche sich bewegt
mit dieser Begegnung im Vatikan geht
eine denkwürdige Reise zu Ende
die Missbrauchs Betroffenen hoffen dass
sie mit ihrer Tour die katholische
Kirche aufrütteln können zugleich wollen
sie anderen Betroffenen Mut machen ihnen
zu folgen
Italien leidet unter Extremwetter Dürre
und Trockenheit hatten Wasserstände
zuletzt auf Tiefstwerte fallen lassen
jetzt wurden Regionen an der Adria Küste
von schweren Unwettern getroffen
starke Regenfälle haben in den Gebieten
in Mehrerau Mania und Marken zu teils
dramatischen Überschwemmungen geführt
mindestens acht Menschen kamen dabei ums
Leben tausende mussten aus den
Wassermassen gerettet werden Annette
hilsenbeck
eine Frau ruft um Hilfe sie ist mit
ihrem kleinen Sohn in den Fluten
gefangen Anwohner Schwimmen zu ihr
retten Kind und Mutter in der Kleinstadt
Cesena nordwestlich von Rimini war der
Fluss Savio rasend schnell angestiegen
überflutete den halben Ort das Umland
in meinem 70-jährigen Leben habe ich den
Fluss noch nie so hoch gesehen
die Situation ist schwierig wenn man
sich hier umblick es ist
besorgniserregend über 1.000
Einsatzkräfte von Feuerwehr und Polizei
retten Tag und Nacht Bewohnerinnen und
Bewohner aus ihren überfluteten
Behausungen noch immer werden Menschen
vermisst
innerhalb eines Tages ging an manchen
Orten der Region ein Drittel des Jahres
Niederschlags herunter in den Monaten
zuvor hatte hier Trockenheit geherrscht
die Böden ausgedacht der zuständige
Minister spricht von einer neuen
Realität
nichts wird mehr sein wie es vorher war
was in diesen Stunden geschieht ist
Zeugnis für künftige lange Dürreperioden
und sehr kurze Perioden heftiger
niederschläger
50.000 Personen waren noch am Mittag
ohne Strom und für die nächsten 24
Stunden gilt in der Region weiterhin
Alarmstufe Rot die italienische
Regierung will nun in einer
Sondersitzung weitere Hilfen auf dem Weg
bringen wegen der Überschwemmungen wurde
auch das Formel 1 Rennen in Imola
inzwischen abgesagt
nach heftigen Unwettern herrscht auch in
Teilen von Kroatien und
Bosnien-Herzegowina Ausnahmezustand
Felder
straßenhäuser und auch ein Nationalpark
wurden überflutet und in manchen Region
steigt das Wasser noch weiter
teils wurde der Notstand ausgerufen
mitsamtsäcken wollen die Menschen
Schlimmeres verhindern denn laut
Prognosen werden die Regenfälle
weitergehen
und wir schauen jetzt dorthin wo sich
gerade die internationalen Filmstars
tummeln bei den Festspielen kann mit der
goldenen ehrenpalme wurde dieses Jahr
schauspiellegende Michael Douglas
ausgezeichnet in Dutzenden Hollywood für
immer damit gespielt Thomas Walder hat
den US-Schauspielerin kann getroffen
frisch geehrt mit einer Goldenen Palme
für sein Lebenswerk zeigt sich Michael
Douglas in kann den Publikum dem ZDF
erklärt er welchen Stellenwert diese
Auszeichnung für ihn hat eine pandor die
Goldene Palme für das Lebenswerk
bedeutet mir eine Menge es gibt hunderte
Filmfestivals auf der Welt aber das kann
Festival ist einzigartig ich habe hier
Spuren und mein Vater hatte die auch
schon dessen Frau war die PR-Frau hier
in Köln
kann die Familie feiert den Filmen und
sich selbst am Nachmittag tummeln sich
die Deutschen auf dem Teppich dem wenn
das mit Anselm Kiefer dessen Leben und
Werk wenn das darstellt begrüßt von
Festival Präsidentin ihres Knoblauch
kurz zuvor war Johnny Depp da mit dem
Team des eröffnungsfilms er äußerte sich
zur Frage ob der Prozess mit seiner
Exfrau ihm noch Anhänge und seine Arbeit
überschatte
sind vielleicht führt das ja dazu dass
die Leute über den Film reden und deine
Arbeit
gehen kann Hand in Hand zum Festival
gehört der Filmmarkt 4000 Werke suchen
hier einen Käufer
kann Filmfest und der Markt dazu ist
eigentlich ja der wichtigste Event vom
ganzen Jahr für uns für die Branche so
prickt kann den Massengeschmack weit
über die Kutte d'Azur hinaus
und jetzt geht es um die Champions
League Sven genauer gesagt ja ums Finale
ja Inter Mailand hat es schon geschafft
heute kämpfen Manchester City und Real
Madrid um den Einzug ins Endspiel vor
einer Woche hieß es nach einem packenden
Duell in Madrid 1:1 Unentschieden
diesmal muss es einen Sieger geben alle
erwarten ein Spektakel
im Hinspiel waren die Torjäger bei der
Teams nahezu wirkungslos Harland von
Rüdiger bestens abgeschirmt auch wenn
Sie immer auf Seiten der Spanier nicht
so auffällig wie gewohnt andere sprangen
ein mit krachenden weit Schüssen der
Brasilianer Junior von Madrid der
belgierte Bräune für ManCity deren Traum
vom ersten Champions League Titel lebt
somit weiter
alle Titel außer diesem haben wir schon
und den wollen wir jetzt auch noch
schon holte sich der spanische
Traditionsklub diesen Titel
wir sind eigentlich schon zufrieden aber
es stimmt für Real ist der finale Einzug
ziemlich normal im Mittelfeld das Duell
von Ilkay Gündogan und Toni Kroos auch
das könnte entscheiden wer am 10 Juni im
Finale steht
und alle Höhepunkte und stimmen zu
diesem Spiel ab 23 Uhr im ZDF dann
wissen wir auch wer der Gegner von Inter
Mailand im Finale sein wird intergewand
gestern auch das Rückspiel im Stadt
derbe gegen Milan lautero Martinez
schoss das Siegtor in der 74 Minute
Inter Mailand hatte zuletzt vor 13
Jahren den Titel geholt
die Frauen des VfL Wolfsburg könnten
morgen zum 9 Mal nacheinander den
DFB-Pokal gewinnen im Finale gegen
Freiburg sind sie favorisiert auch wenn
die Titel Euphorie am Wochenende
gebremst wurde im Champions League
Finale stehen sie auch doch nach dem 0:4
zuletzt in Frankfurt ist der deutsche
Meistertitel für die Wolfsburgerinnen so
gut wie verloren beim Abo auf den
DFB-Pokal soll es aber bleiben
wird nur ein Spiel und wir müssen direkt
da sein unser Teil unser Gesicht zeigen
unser Spielweise zeigen und das ist
unser Thema morgen mehr als 40.000
Zuschauer in Köln könnten aber auch den
ersten Titel Gewinn der Außenseiterinnen
aus Freiburg miterleben bei denen der
Glaube daran ohne behörbar ist in
wirklich fest davon überzeugt dass es
wirklich in einem Spiel machbar ist und
dass man auch wirklich als Außenseiter
schaffen kann Finale zu gewinnen und ähm
genauso werden wir auch ein Spiel gehen
Wolfsburg kann den DFB-Pokal zum
insgesamt 10 Mal gewinnen das hat noch
kein Frauenteam geschafft
überall Endspiel Jana das war Dankeschön
Sven und diese Lottozahlen wurden
gezogen
die Gewinnzahlen lauten 26 29 31 36 45
Superzahl ist die 6 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
nach einer sehr frischen Nacht wird der
Feiertag morgen trocken und kühl mit
Sonne und wollten mehr zum Wetter gleich
von Katja horneffer das heute journal
läuft um 21:45 Uhr mit Dunja Hayali
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend sicherlich haben Sie von den
kräftigen Regenfällen und
Überschwemmungen besonders hier im
Norden Italiens gehört die gute
Nachricht für diese Region ist der Regen
lässt wenigstens vorübergehend nach der
Regen ist das eine große Thema beim
Wetter die Temperaturen sind das andere
denn heute Nacht droht in Deutschland
noch mal verbreitet Bodenfrost ihre
empfindlichen Pflanzen sollten Sie also
schützen etwas mildes es ist einzig dort
wo es ein paar dichtere Wolkenfelder
gibt ganz im Norden und ganz im Süden
der Feiertag morgen wird sehr freundlich
Sonnenschein und Wolken wechseln sich
miteinander ab mal geht es mir Wolken
mal dominiert die Sonne und der Wind
weht nur leicht aus nördlichen
Richtungen und so bleibt es morgen noch
kühl mit 11 Grad am alten Rand und 18
Grad am Rhein aber diese Temperaturen
werden wir steigern am Sonntag liegen
die Werte dann am Alpenrand bei 22 und
hier südlich von Berlin sogar bei bis zu
29 Grad das klingt schon nach Frühsommer
strahlenden Sonnenschein gibt's dabei
aber nicht denn die Luft ist recht
feucht so entwickeln sich kräftige
Regenschauer und Gewitter am Sonntag vor
allen Dingen im Norden aber auch im
Süden Deutschlands